los que nos seguís habitualmente lo
sabéis bien aquí en visual político la
rusia de vladimir putin es uno de los
temas estrella uno de los temas que más
solemos tratar hasta ahora en otros
vídeos ya hemos echado un vistazo entre
otros temas a las implicaciones de rt a
la estrategia de seguridad y defensa de
putin o incluso a sus resultados
económicos sin embargo nos faltaba un
tema clave y por el que de una forma u
otra muchos de vosotros nos habéis
preguntado teníamos pendiente analizar
por que putin es tan popular dentro de
rusia así que dicho y hecho
veámoslo por cierto al final del vídeo
os tenemos una pequeña sorpresa y un
pequeño reto
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dicen que después de la tormenta siempre
llega la calma bueno pues en el caso de
rusia esto es literal tras atravesar una
durísima crisis en los últimos años por
la caída del precio del petróleo y las
materias primas por un lado y por las
sanciones de la comunidad internacional
tras la ocupación de crimea por otro el
gobierno ha sido contundente los tiempos
difíciles ya han pasado la economía rusa
el gran oso ruso está de vuelta pero de
verdad algunos dicen que la prueba de
que este gobierno ha capitaneado la
crisis mejor que ningún otro es que su
crecimiento en 2017 será del 12% del 9
del 5 del 3 del 21 del 1% mes tras mes
la economía de rusia crece para 2017
esperamos que el crecimiento sea del 1%
o incluso más la verdad mucho lo que se
dice mucho
no parece y eso teniendo en cuenta que
rusia no es un país precisamente rico y
siempre y cuando nos creamos ciegamente
las estadísticas del gobierno ruso que
bueno cada vez
más analistas consideran que como decir
no tiene mucho de literatura de ciencia
ficción lo cierto es que aunque es
verdad que todo apunta a que la economía
rusa se está estabilizando los últimos
años no han sido precisamente fáciles
para los rusos según el instituto ruso
para las previsiones sociales tan sólo
en 2016 los ciudadanos rusos sufrieron
la mayor pérdida del poder adquisitivo
séase de ingresos reales desde los
turbulentos años 90 que se dice pronto
la crisis y la depreciación sufrida por
el rublo la moneda de rusia ha provocado
que hoy este país con 145 millones de
habitantes tenga un pib similar al de
australia cuya población apenas es de 23
millones y lo que es aún peor hoy por
hoy no hay perspectivas de que la
situación vaya a mejorar pues bien he
aquí la gran anomalía rusa la prueba de
que este país prácticamente es diferente
a cualquier otro ni la crisis ni los
malos resultados económicos y sociales
han dañado la popularidad nacional de
vladimir putin
la popularidad del líder ruso se
encuentra hoy prácticamente en récord
histórico según sondeos del centro de
levada la aprobación de putin entre el
pueblo ruso supera el 80 por ciento
fijaos
[Música]
pero puede que os estáis preguntando
cómo es esto posible cómo puede ser que
a este hombre la crisis no le pase
factura veamos que está pasando
el padre protector hablar de la economía
rusa supone necesariamente hablar de
petróleo y materias primas para que os
hagáis una idea de la gran dependencia
que rusia tiene de estos dos recursos
dos datos antes del hundimiento de los
precios del crudo el petróleo y el gas
natural suponían ni más ni menos que el
70 por ciento de las exportaciones del
país y más del 50 por ciento de todos
los ingresos del gobierno ruso
[Música]
y fijaos cómo ha evolucionado el precio
del petróleo bajo el mandato de putin
vamos que prácticamente podemos decir
que vladimir putin tuvo un golpe de
suerte descomunal nada más llegar al
poder el precio del barril de petróleo
que se había mantenido estable alrededor
de los 20 dólares durante los últimos 10
años comenzó a dispararse para que os
hagáis una idea el peso del gobierno y
la economía rusa pasó del 35 por ciento
al 70 por ciento de repente la
prosperidad llegó a todo el país en las
ciudades había grúas por todas partes
los rascacielos crecían como setas y el
nivel de vida de los rusos subía y subía
sí es verdad
putin dio muestras muy tempranas de
cierto autoritarismo pero y que el
dinero fluya podemos decir que se forjó
una especie de pacto entre la sociedad
rusa y su líder a cambio de no preguntar
por las libertades civiles o la
corrupción el gobierno garantizaba la
estabilidad y prosperidad de la gente
[Música]
es decir putin se convirtió así en una
especie de padre protector severo sí
pero capaz de cuidar de sus hijos
el problema como siempre es que estas
situaciones por decirlo de alguna forma
son muy endebles y por supuesto ningún
gobierno ni siquiera el de putin tiene
la capacidad mágica de garantizar por sí
mismo la prosperidad con el precio del
petróleo por las nubes
putin no hizo reformas para que de tal
forma que cuando en el verano de 2014 el
precio del crudo comenzó a venirse abajo
la economía rusa fue detrás pues bien
aquí llegamos sin duda al punto más
interesante
nada de esto afectó a la popularidad de
putin el presidente ruso supo cómo
decirlo reciclar su estrategia si en un
principio fue el garante de la
prosperidad ahora tocaba a re
convertirse en el líder que recuperaría
toda la influencia de la madre rusia
el fervor nacionalista
si la economía no carburaba tocaba
buscar otra fuente de popularidad y
putin la supo encontrar durante
quinientos años amigos de visual
política la ambición de la política
exterior rusa estuvo incluso por encima
de sus capacidades desde ivan el
terrible allá por el siglo 16 rusia
extendió su territorio un promedio ojo
de 80 kilómetros cuadrados al día hasta
llegar a convertirse con mucha
diferencia en el país más grande de la
tierra y también en uno de los más
poderosos sin embargo tras la caída de
la unión soviética rusia entró en una
espiral muy negativa de pérdida de
influencia
pues bien esta es la nueva promesa de
putin que podríamos resumir así puede
que no haya prosperidad o que la
situación económica no sea buena pero yo
vladimir putin conseguir que rusia
recupere su peso en el mundo no seréis
un pueblo rico pero nuestra nación será
fuerte pero claro para que esta
estrategia funcione hacen falta varias
cosas la primera de ellas es ensalzar el
sentimiento nacionalista rusia rusia y
rusia putin inaugura un gigantesco
monumento al príncipe
vladimir el re unificador de las tierras
rusas por cierto en la misma línea están
los constantes anuncios de nuevas armas
invencibles muy poderosas y que
garantizan a rusia su estatus y
supremacía veremos si esas armas
funciona pero lo que sí que es muy
dudoso es que el gobierno ruso pueda
siquiera pagarlas la segunda clave
necesaria amigos pasa por buscar
enemigos que sean capaces de cuestionar
al pueblo ruso en una meta común es
decir me explico
se necesita una amenaza a una agresión
un objetivo que une a los rusos y para
esto putin necesita una política
exterior agresiva la crisis ucraniana
a las intenciones de la otan y la
ocupación de crimea por ejemplo hicieron
repuntar muchísimo su popularidad a ojos
del pueblo ruso putin está devolviendo
al país a sus tiempos de gloria
[Música]
este segundo punto explica la cargada
agenda que la diplomacia rusa tiene en
los últimos años puede que no tengan
dinero pero moscú está en todas partes
ucrania siria el norte de áfrica
y ojo para ser sinceros las sanciones
que la comunidad internacional le impuso
a rusia tras la ocupación de cream ya
han tenido el efecto contrario al
pretendido en general han sido vistas
por los rusos como una humillación y si
algo han conseguido es apuntalar el
apoyo a vladimir putin el 74% de los
rusos considera que las sanciones están
dirigidas a debilitar y humillar a rusia
sólo el 5% considera que son un
instrumento para detener el conflicto en
ucrania y por último también hace falta
otra cosa consolidar la imagen de un
líder fuerte aguerrido casi un héroe
nacional un salvador mientras haya putin
habrá rusia cuando putin se vaya no
habrá más rusia pues bien amigos esta es
la clave de que vladimir putin haya
conseguido mantener e incluso
incrementar su popularidad ya no es el
garante de la prosperidad ahora es el
líder que recuperará el poder de la
madre rusia
el capitalismo de amiguetes otra
cuestión que tenemos que tener muy
presente es que el gobierno de putin
sobrevive en buena medida porque ha
sabido crear a su alrededor una órbita
de nuevos oligarcas una órbita muy
poderosa que se ha hecho de oro
extrayendo recursos del estado ruso la
concesión de ayudas para capear la
crisis la entrega a dedo de grandes
contratos públicos o la apuesta de putin
por sustituir importaciones han
beneficiado directamente a estos
oligarcas casi todos multimillonarios en
2015 putin concedió a su compañero de
yudo arcadi rothenberg un contrato de 4
mil millones de dólares para construir
un puente entre rusia y creamer y además
putin se guarda un as bajo la manga por
si las cosas vienen mal dadas privatizar
o mejor dicho entregar a las empresas
públicas a estos oligarcas que ponen su
poder y su dinero al servicio de
vladimir putin el presidente ruso ha
dejado claro que sólo participarán en
las privatizaciones inversores
estratégicos es decir inversores
elegidos e invitados expresamente por el
gobierno ruso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
de hierro
y por último no podía faltar la
represión política y la represión a
minorías es el juguete favorito de todos
los dictadores y también de quienes lo
son en potencia leer por ejemplo el
último informe de amnistía internacional
sobre los derechos humanos en rusia es
trágico durante 2016 se intensificaron
las restricciones del derecho a la
libertad de expresión asociación y
reunión pacífica pues bien amigos ya lo
tenemos esta es la receta que explica la
gran popularidad de putin en rusia
nacionalismo oligarcas y censura y
represión política
vladimir putin ha prometido al pueblo
volverá a ser poderosos a cambio de su
lealtad incondicional sin embargo no
parece que rusia pueda a medio y largo
plazo competir seriamente con eeuu o
china pero tú como lo ves logrará putin
devolver a rusia su poder que prefieres
poder de la nación o bienestar
prosperidad y libertad para los
ciudadanos nosotros lo tenemos claro
pero esperamos tu respuesta en los
comentarios por cierto os he dicho al
principio que teníamos para vosotros una
sorpresa un reto pues bien lo prometido
es deuda aquí lo tenéis
enrique tengo un problema no sé qué
camisa ponerme hoy marianna las jornadas
de finanzas el nombre no ha bueno el
concurso de camisetas no el concurso de
vídeos como de vídeos si han montado
también un concurso de vídeos en youtube
y vimeo y no veas qué premios a ver a
ver en qué consiste todo esto
josé carlos cuentas más detalles los
vídeos tienen que tener entre uno y seis
minutos de duración el formato es
completamente libre
dicho esto queréis participar pues
recordar que la fecha límite es el 7 de
mayo de 2017 y como podéis presentar
vuestros trabajos al jurado os
preguntaréis pues muy sencillo sólo
tenéis que subir vuestros vídeos a
alguna plataforma como youtube o vimeo y
después le envías el link a las
dirección de correo electrónico
concursos arroba juan de mariana punto o
hereje mucha suerte y mucho ánimo a los
participantes así que ya sabes si te
gusta la libertad o simplemente quieres
contarle algo al mundo que no te venza
el miedo no dudes en apuntarte tan solo
necesitas tu ingenio y tu creatividad
para más información en la web del
instituto
[Música]